Speaker 1: Well, I woke up this morning and
I said to myself, Sir, we should really do
a show today.
There's a lot going on.
And so here we are.
That's the context in which today's program
is being produced.
One programing note, dozens of people writing
to me breathlessly.
You could tell, even though it was written
text, that people were breathless saying,
David, when is your Lex Freedman appearance
coming out?
I don't know the answer, but I. Lex said it
would be three or four days from when we filmed
it earlier this week.
So I would guess by the end of this week.
But I don't know and I don't have any control
over it.
But I'm is I'm as eager to take a look at
it as some of the other folks in the audience
are.
So we'll know about that very, very soon.
All right.
Listen, I've been waiting for this and it
is now happening.
Republicans, right wingers, MAGA types Steven
Crowder and others are now coming after what
we call no fault divorce, which essentially
translates to they want to force women to
have to stay married unless they can give
what some consider an acceptable reason for
why they should be allowed to get divorced.
What on earth am I talking about?
Let's backtrack and let's set it up.
I had no plan to talk about right wing content
creator Stephen Crowder's divorce on the podcast.
There's really just no reason to talk about
it.
I don't know.
There's nothing particularly newsworthy about
it except when I watched his brief explanation
of the personal trouble that he's having,
including this very contentious divorce, he
seemed to sort of bemoan the fact that his
wife can just say, hey, I want a divorce,
and it's called no fault divorce.
You don't have to prove that someone cheated
or whatever to justify the divorce.
You're just allowed to say, I don't want to
be in this marriage anymore.
And in the video that Steven Crowder put out
about this, he seemed to be sort of suggesting
that that's a problem, that that's not okay.
His wife maybe should be forced to stay married
to him.
And he's not the only one who feels this way.
Let's take a listen.
This is the video from I guess now.
It's been about a week since this news broke
to the extent that it's news.
Speaker 2: I have been living with a proverbial
boot on my neck for going on years now.
Since 2021, I've been living through what
has increasingly been a horrendous divorce.
Now, let me say on the outset, to be clear,
there is no infidelity, any kind of physical
abuse at all on either side.
And no, this was not my choice.
My then wife decided that she didn't want
to be married anymore.
And in the state of Texas, that is completely
permitted.
Speaker 1: It's it's permitted.
It's allowed.
As crazy as it is, you're just allowed to
say, I don't want to be married anymore, and
I can't control that.
So this is now building into a bigger story.
And there's a very interesting Rolling Stone
article, The next front in the Republicans
War on Women.
No fault divorce.
Steven Crowder is part of a growing right
wing chorus calling for an end to modern divorce
laws.
And the article explains, and you can check
it out.
Steven Crowder is getting a divorce.
He says it's not his choice.
He says his wife is just allowed to do it.
And the article says Crowder's emphasis on
the state of Texas makes it sound like the
Lone Star State is an outlier.
But all 50 states and the District of Columbia
have no fault divorce laws on the books, laws
that allow either party to walk away from
an unhappy marriage without having to prove
abuse, infidelity or other misconduct.
Republicans are now unsure whether this is
something that they actually want.
And the article goes on to say, like the Crusades
against abortion and contraception, making
it more difficult to leave an unhappy marriage
is about control.
Crowder's home state could be the first to
eliminate it if the Texas Republican Party
gets its way.
Last year, the Republican Party of Texas added
language to its platform, calling to an end
to no fault divorce.
This is another way to potentially control
women.
That's what this is fundamentally about.
No fault.
Divorce is a legal process, which basically
just means you can end a marriage without
having to prove that any spouse is at fault
for the breakdown of the marriage and the
history of no fault divorce in the United
States goes back to the early 20th century.
But it really wasn't until the 1970s that
no fault divorce had widespread acceptance
and before you had no fault divorce.
I sound like Trump.
Many people don't know this.
A lot of people have no reason to think about
this.
But before there was no fault divorce, divorce
laws in the U.S. were based on fault.
And what that meant is in order to be granted
a divorce, in order to be allowed to get a
divorce, one spouse had to prove that the
other spouse was at fault for the failure
of the marriage, and often it was adultery,
cruelty, some kind of abandonment like they've
basically left already anyway, sometimes insanity
or, you know, what we might call mental illness.
And then in the sixties and seventies, states
started to rightfully reconsider that and
say, hey, you know, maybe people in the same
way that they can choose to get married should
just be allowed to choose to no longer be
married anymore.
And California was the first to pass no fault
divorce in 1969.
And then by the end of the 1970s, most states
had done the same thing.
The really important thing to understand here,
aside from what I believe to be the obvious
logic, that you shouldn't have to make a case
to be allowed to get divorced, you should
just be able to say, I don't want to be married
anymore.
It's worth mentioning that no fault divorce
significantly improve the lives of women as
well as children in many situations by giving
them greater legal protections and more equitable
outcomes in divorce proceedings.
Now there is the you'll have the men's rights
activists who love to say men routinely and
and sort of systematically get screwed over
when it comes to custody in divorce proceedings.
And it's unfair in all these different things.
I consider that to be a different issue that
can be discussed on its merits.
But understand that prior to the introduction
of no fault divorce, particularly because
it was during an era where women were statistically
less likely to work, or if they work, they
were statistically likely to be earning less
money than the husband in a heterosexual marriage.
They were more likely to be dramatically disadvantaged
and controlled by the lack of no fault divorce.
And so no no fault divorce, as obvious as
it is to many of us and as standard as it
is in so many other Western developed nations,
it actually was a really significant change
and and liberating to some degree, providing
additional rights to many women as it became
more common during the 1970s.
So it's not a surprise given that Republicans
love policy that allows women to be controlled.
Let's control what women can do with their
bodies.
Let's control medically, etc..
Given all of that, it's not a surprise that
they found yet another issue on which they
want to go back to the 1950s.
And again, that's quite literally what we're
talking about.
This was the law of the land.
In the 1950s started changing.
69 into the seventies.
I had an inkling when I saw the Crowder video,
They're going to go after this no fault divorce.
And now that is in and of itself becoming
a bigger story.
Horrifying stuff.
But it is the party.
It is the movement of going back to the 1950s.
All right.